this is something that people tend to
avoid because it's
it's painful yeah um but but
i think this is a very common mistake my
father did bit me a big favor he had me
working in all my spare time from the
time i was six i spent an unusual amount
of time
with my grandparents and especially with
my grandfather on the ranch
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
too you've got michael jordan level
genius at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the seven
rich people habits that you need to try
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one look for
negative feedback with elon musk it's
very important to
to seek out to actively seek out
and listen very carefully to negative
feedback
um and this is something that people
tend to
avoid because it's it's painful yeah um
but but i think this is a very common
mistake
is to to not actively seek out
and listen to uh negative feedback what
do you do that you go into forums do you
go into twitter like what are your
areas where you go to look for feedback
on let's say the tesla well
it's like everyone i talk to is in fact
when um when friends get a product i say
look
i don't tell me what you like tell me
what you don't like right
um and and because otherwise your friend
is not going to tell you what he doesn't
like
right this girl's going to say oh i love
this and that and and then
and leave out the this is the stuff i
don't like list because too much of your
friend want
you know it doesn't want to offend you
so um
so you really need to
[Music]
to to to to sort of coax negative
feedback um
and you should you know that if somebody
is your is your friend or at least
not your enemy and they're giving you
negative feedback um
then they may be wrong but it's coming
from a good place
and sometimes even your enemies give you
good negative feedback habit number two
build resourcefulness with jeff bezos i
spent an
unusual amount of time with my
grandparents and especially with my
grandfather on the ranch so he had a
ranch in south texas
and i would spend my summers there from
age 4 to 16.
and they when i was four they were
taking me for the summer to kind of give
my parents a break
you know it's sort of because they were
so young
and it was useful i was a handful i'm
sure
and uh anyway he he
he he created the illusion for me when i
was four years old that i was helping
him
on the ranch which of course could not
have been true
but i believed it and um and then as
by the time i was 16 of course i was
actually helping on the ranch i
you know i could i can fix prolapsed
cattle i can
you know we did all of our own
veterinary work some of the cattle even
survived
and we fixed windmills and laid you know
water pipelines and built fences and
barns and
fixed that fixed the bulldozer that you
guys talked about
and so one of the things that's so
interesting about
that lifestyle and about my grandfather
is he did everything himself you know he
didn't call a vet
if one of the animals was sick he
figured out what to do himself
and so what does it mean no delegation
being resourceful
i think is the you know that you can
always you can't if there's a problem
there's a solution and of course as you
as you
mature and and get into the business
world and anything you do on a team you
very quickly realize that
it's not about just your own
resourcefulness it's about
team resourcefulness and how does that
work and habit number three
work productively with charles koch i
discovered at an early age i didn't
think i was much good at anything
and but my father did bit me a big favor
he had me
working in all my spare time from the
time i was six
because he he announced he didn't want
his sons to
be country club bombs he wanted us to
feel
grateful for everything and entitled to
nothing
and and for whatever reason when you say
working he didn't give you some cushy
office job in the company no no no not
particularly at age six i started out
digging dandelions and when i say dig
dandelions you don't pull them out
you dig them down and you have to get
the entire route or they'll come
right back and i remember there was a
club and a swimming pool across the
street from us and i'm out there in 105
degree heat digging these and i could
hear
my friends my little six-year-old
friends
they're swimming and jumping off the
diving board and i could recognize
each one squeal was different of joy
and i'm thinking why does my father hate
me and their fathers love them i found
out
that if you don't and then and then i of
course graduated to shoveling
out stalls and milking cows
and that doesn't sound like much work
but oh
it it's it's hard work so i would milk
cows before school and then again after
school
martin milk milk or cows and digging
post holes and all these things
but i discovered that much later
that if if you don't learn to do dirty
jobs if you don't learn
unpleasant work you by the time you're
in your 30s you never learn to work
productively
and so he was doing me a huge favor so
it was beyond
the work ethic it taught you how to work
productively and how to work with others
in mutual benefit for example if a group
of you during a dirty job
you don't try to stick it to them make
them do more then they'll try to do it
to you
and the work goes on and on you want to
work together
to get it done as efficiently as
possible you want to understand
who your customer is how do what does my
customer want what
what does he value i better do this the
right way or i'll have to do it again
habit number four hold yourself
accountable with steve ballmer
you better stay on top of yourself and
and really
measure unless people measure themselves
you don't get any better you cannot
succeed
unless you are really holding yourself
accountable and owning outcomes
believe me i've seen plenty of people at
microsoft various places in the tech
industry
brilliant people who when it came time
to execute and actually count success
and maybe not so much maybe not so much
you could in order to do that you have
to actually know what the goal is
if the goal was to get the 450 million
users
and then sell the facebook whatsapp did
a hell of a job
right i mean that that's not a i mean
it's a hell of a job at 19 billion 55
people that's a hell of a job
but you have to decide what outcome do
you want
bill gates was offered seven and a half
million dollars to sell all of microsoft
in 1979.
it would have been a rich guy if he had
taken it
richer if he didn't but a rich guy but
even putting that aside the impact on
society wouldn't have been the same
we had discussions with facebook about
buying facebook but zuckerberg knew
what he viewed as a an outcome that he
really desired and was willing to put in
the blood sweat and tears just like we
were
so execution and measurement are
hugely important and yet people let
themselves
off the hook habit number five beat the
sun
up with grant cardone grant rant
of the day the one you need to live with
wake up to every day
is that right there okay
beat the sun up folks you got to beat
the sun up if you can't
beat up the roll-up of the sunnah
you're going to get beat up in life okay
i've been doing this for a long time now
i'd say beat that thing up that monster
out there that warms this planet
that nourishes and gives us light
but you can't live a 10x life if you're
not beating the sun up
so many of you complain about how much
time you have you don't have time man
because you don't beat the sun
up get started early and when you get
started early that means you need
to shut it down early okay shut it down
early so you get sleep i was i was i was
asleep last night at nine o'clock
so i could beat the sun up tomorrow this
morning and see
the world wake up with me hey man
how you doing buddy good how are you you
got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here habit
number six be ready to learn with jack
ma
today the 18 founders of alibaba a lot
of people
think they are legendary something wow
you all hibaba founders you must be
super good at honestly most of us cannot
find
jobs early days we're not that smart
none of us graduate from a you know a
great university
um but the thing is that we are ready to
learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we learn we
improve we'll be there i told them for
the first year
everybody forget about that you will be
vp vice president
right you will always be a tiny manager
in your life
because if we're successful people will
hide they will be smarter than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
and you will be happy because this is
the mission that we have
so i would say there's no best
people in the world that is suit ready
for you
the best of people is always you find
the right people
working together training him developing
him
and he training you he developed if then
you have a chance to build a team
and habit number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip is
expose yourself to new things with
mark cuban same thing i told myself the
same thing i tell everybody
one you're 21 22 23 years old
right you don't have to figure it out
right now don't try
right you spend all this money sorry
um paying to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn and start
to be exposed to different ideas and now
it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago you know it was
like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for
ibm or general motors and get a pension
those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so you're a free agent
and you're always going to be a free
agent on the market you guys are the
kevin durants and lebron james
you know where you're always out there
and can go find a better situation for
yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
yumeki um
um you know what was how bad could it be
i would lose my motel sixth towel you
know
it was just like what have you got to
lose and yeah i understand there's
pressure from student loans and there's
a lot of conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect
you can learn at that job and you guys
have the pedigree you have the brains
you have the initiative to go out and
try the next job
you know you know the good news is the
economy is good enough that it may not
be perfect but you can go job to job
don't look for the perfect answer just
look to get the experience look to learn
because all these different exposures
all the different things you learn
learning how to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juice you for for something
that you love
because once you find something you love
to do
that's when the magic happens because
when you're when you're
able to find something you love to do
then you can start work focusing on how
can i be great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself
then you can try to be great at it and
it's rare when people
quit things they're great at you know
and so
trying those things so that that's how i
advise people don't don't stress just go
out and try different things
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch something and get motivated
and just get inspired you have a 35
chance of actually following through but
when you get motivated and then you
actually create an action plan
for what you're gonna do you increase it
from 35 percent to 91
chance of you actually following through
and when you share your plan publicly
that jumps to 95 chance of following
through so i want that for you i want to
know your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week put it down in the
comments below
so i can celebrate you there's this
culture in silicon valley that kind of
makes startups seem glamorous and
i never really believed that right i
never had a goal of starting
a startup and my goal
when i realized that i had a company was
to get it to be
a good company as quickly as possible
right and kind of get out of what you'd
call the like risky
startup phase where you are just like
constantly about to die
and where you could get to a point where
you can actually do some interesting
things and make make a lot of more
interesting bets
and um so i don't know i never read a
lot of the literature on this and i mean
maybe if i had then i wouldn't have made
so many mistakes
but so i don't know if like if learning
for me is the right way to go on this
but
i mean but it did i think your model
must have come from somewhere though
even if it was
even if you it was unintentional right
like were you influenced by peter thiel
or sean yes i was people seeing all
these people
once i met them i actually i hadn't
really heard of peter thiel before
i'm talking about like yeah right yeah
but he was massively influential on my
thinking right i mean
like a lot of the uh the early lessons
that i took
on how to think about strategy came from
peter and sean
and um i did pay a lot of attention when
i was growing up to microsoft i thought
i mean i grew up you know using you know
windows 3.1 and then windows 95 and i
just thought that those were like
the most unbelievable things and in that
sense they are
yeah they really were awesome right um
well i don't know if you you meant that
positive positively but
i did um and and i thought you know
building this ecosystem was really neat
and that kind of inspired me right
in the way that they built a platform i
kind of thought okay well maybe one day
you know the tools that i'm building can
be part of a broader ecosystem as well
if you want to know the routines you
must try to become rich check out the
video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there i believe that
potential unexpressed
turns to pain remember that day that you
sat there and were furious and pissed
off all day over something that you
couldn't control
why'd you waste that day